Hi, everyone.
My name is Brandon Leshchinskiy,
and I'm a graduate student here
at MIT.
Now the presentation
that you're watching
was created by an organization
here at MIT called Earth DNA,
but it's going to be shared
with high school students
all around the country.
And so I'm really excited to
be sharing it with you guys.
Welcome.
This talk is going to have
some audience interaction.
So to get everybody warmed
up, please just yell out
your own name on three.
Ready?
One, two, three.
[ALL YELLING]
Nice to meet you.
Like I said, I'm Brandon.
Now in this talk,
we're going to cover
four things: the truth, the
consequences, the myths,
and the future.
And I want to start
with the truth.
In particular, let's review the
science of what's happening.
We'll go through it slowly.
In 1896, a scientist discovered
the greenhouse effect.
Can somebody here tell me
what the greenhouse effect is?
Does anyone here know?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's the part of
the atmosphere sun's rays
go inside it and then
it's difficult for them
to get outside of it, so it
keeps the earth's atmosphere
at a normal temperature.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Cool.
It's part of the sun's--
it's part of the
earth's atmosphere
that keeps our temperature
warm and normal.
OK.
Anybody else?
What is the greenhouse effect?
Yes?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So there
are certain gases
that trap heat and
release that heat
after it's trapped--
it's something called
the radiative forcing.
And so some-- for a lot of
gases in the atmosphere,
like nitrogen, sun rays
just pass right through.
But for a select few,
like water and carbon
dioxide, that absorb
infrared light and then
for red spectrum, and then that
traps heat in the atmosphere
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Fantastic.
You must know your
climate science.
But that's exactly right.
And the basic idea
is that some gases
in our atmosphere trap heat.
And you can see here how light
from the sun hits the Earth.
It gets converted into heat.
And it gets trapped underneath
this atmospheric blanket.
We emit these greenhouse
gases by burning fossil fuels
for transportation
and electricity.
Things like driving,
flying, air conditioning.
These all emit greenhouse
gases into the atmosphere
as we burn fossil fuels like
oil, gas, and coal, greenhouse
gas concentrations rise.
You can see here
that since 2005,
the amount of carbon dioxide,
one of the main greenhouse
gases, has increased steadily.
Here's that same
graph since 1700.
You can see the Industrial
Revolution happening in 1760,
and shortly thereafter
we start to see
this increase in the
amount of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere.
Here's the last 800,000 years.
Now notice in the
last 800,000 years,
the maximum carbon dioxide level
has been 300 parts per million.
300,000 years ago is the
oldest Homo sapiens fossil.
That's us.
The Industrial Revolution
happened in 1760,
a little under 300 years ago.
And here's where we are now.
Atmospheric greenhouse
gases have spiked.
As humans emit more
greenhouse gases,
our atmosphere traps more heat
and the earth gets warmer.
You can see here the
global temperature
anomaly from NASA over time.
It starts with lots
of blues and reds,
meaning things
are pretty normal.
But as time goes on
from 1950 to today,
it gets redder and
redder and redder.
That's earth warming to 0.82
degrees Celsius above normal,
or 1.5 degrees Fahrenheit.
Now, I know what
you're thinking.
I know what you're thinking.
Who cares about 1.5
degrees Fahrenheit?
That's like nothing and I
can barely even feel it.
Well, to answer
this question, we
have to talk about
the consequences.
Climate change
already affects us.
Whether it's through
wildfires in California,
or flooding in the Midwest, or
hurricanes on the east coast,
the effects of climate
change are already here.
Heat waves, floods,
and other disasters
are becoming more frequent.
You can see the recorded
natural disasters per year
has skyrocketed since the 1960s.
In Boston, the city
is already planning
seawalls because of more
intense and frequent flooding.
We are already
doing these things.
In other words, cities must
spend your parents' tax
money on climate adaptations
instead of schools, transit,
and hospitals.
Unusual weather
also affects food.
By 2030, a drought could
double the price of corn.
And maybe you don't
like corn, but I bet you
like chicken or fish, which
are both raised on corn feed.
Or maybe you like high fructose
corn syrup in cereal or bread.
The point is corn is
in a lot of foods,
and by stifling crop
growth climate change
limits food access.
Of course, it's not
just corn either.
But at any rate, climate
change also affects water.
This woman migrated over 150
miles because of a drought.
By 2050, the UN projects 200
million environmental migrants.
These are people who
leave their homes because
of changes in the environment.
And my question to you is this.
In recent migrant crises,
thousands of refugees
created turmoil in
Europe and America.
What happens when
millions of people
move north in search of
food, water, and safety?
Can we handle that?
I'm not sure.
Even the US military
refers to climate change
as a threat multiplier,
because it makes
every bad situation worse.
And by the way, the
Pentagon has released
reports about climate change
under both Democratic and
Republican administrations.
This is not a partisan issue.
These problems are not
just in the future either.
They're happening right now.
The current species
extinction rate
is 1,000 times
higher than normal.
If pollinators go, so do we.
There's no more crops left.
We're on track for one
million species extinctions,
and here's what just
one of those looks like.
We could live more
sustainably, so why don't we?
And to really
understand this, we
have to talk about the myths.
And I want to set the stage
with a game called Commons.
So at this point,
I want everybody
to form groups of five and
count off from one to five.
Go ahead and sit in a circle.
You guys can stand
up, form groups.
I'll give you a second
to make this happen.
It might be easier for people
in the front row to kind of move
to--
turn your chairs
to face the back.
Because we're going to
be sitting in a circle.
Cool.
OK.
And everybody count off from
1 to 5 within your groups.
AUDIENCE: 1.
AUDIENCE: 2.
AUDIENCE: 3.
AUDIENCE: 4.
AUDIENCE: 1.
AUDIENCE: 2.
AUDIENCE: 3.
AUDIENCE: 4.
AUDIENCE: 5.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: OK.
Has everybody counted off?
We good to go?
OK.
So you're going to all
start a pond with 20 fish.
This is your pond's
carrying capacity.
Your goal at the end
of the game, the winner
is the person in the
room with the most fish.
And remember, you win as an
individual, not as a group.
Here's how the game
actually works.
Each round, every
person in your group
will take between
one and four fish.
You have to take at
least one, but you
can't take more than four.
After each round,
your pond will be
restocked by doubling the number
of fish without exceeding 20.
So four fish becomes 8,
nine fish becomes 18,
10 fish or more brings
the pond back to 20.
Does that make sense?
For the group of
four in the back,
your carrying
capacity is actually
going to be four times the
number of people in your group,
so you're going to have 16.
And so all the same
rules apply where
if you double the number
of fish, at eight or higher
you'll go back to 16.
You will never have a
pond with 20 fish in it.
Does that make sense
to the group of four?
Great.
Don't eat the goldfish yet.
And if you have allergies,
don't eat the goldfish at all.
So if everybody could
send person number one up
to the front, I can
hand you guys goldfish.
Thank you.
Great.
So everybody should have a
pond and a restock supply.
And can everybody just make sure
that you have the right number
of fish in your pond?
So it's four times the number
of people in your group.
Everybody just make sure.
Everybody good?
OK.
You guys have 30 seconds to
discuss strategy starting now.
[STUDENTS ALL SPEAKING]
Round one.
Take turns going clockwise,
starting with player three.
You have 60 seconds.
[STUDENTS ALL SPEAKING]
Go ahead and restock your ponds.
You have 30 seconds
to do this each time.
You'll play four rounds.
Everybody good?
Gonna go ahead and skip.
Round two, starting
with player two.
[STUDENTS ALL SPEAKING]
[BUZZER SOUNDING]
Restock.
You have 30 seconds.
AUDIENCE: Adding 11 this time.
AUDIENCE: No, you
only get to double.
AUDIENCE: Oh, shit.
So we're going [INAUDIBLE].
[BUZZER SOUNDING]
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
Round three.
Take turns, starting
with player four.
AUDIENCE: How many did you take?
AUDIENCE: Two.
AUDIENCE: Oh, what a guy.
[STUDENTS ALL SPEAKING]
Does anybody need more time?
I'm going to go
ahead and skip again.
[BUZZER SOUNDING]
Go ahead and restock.
[STUDENTS ALL SPEAKING]
Everybody good?
Cool.
[BUZZER SOUNDING]
Final round.
Start with player three.
[STUDENTS ALL SPEAKING]
AUDIENCE: What are you doing?
AUDIENCE: It's the last turn.
[STUDENTS ALL SPEAKING]
AUDIENCE: Did you take two?
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
Is everybody set?
Anybody need more time?
Cool.
[BUZZER SOUNDING]
Let's do one last
round just for fun.
AUDIENCE: No!
[LAUGHING]
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: So who
still has fish in their pond?
Cool.
OK.
So we're actually doing this.
Sometimes we don't.
Go ahead and restock your ponds.
You guys have 30 seconds.
[STUDENTS ALL SPEAKING]
Are you guys all set?
You guys are restocked?
AUDIENCE: We already started.
Yeah.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Cool.
All right, I'm going to
go out and skip ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
[BUZZER SOUNDING]
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Final
round for real this time.
Take turns going clockwise,
starting with player number
one.
[STUDENTS ALL SPEAKING]
All right.
Is everybody good?
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Is it
for real this time?
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: All right.
[BUZZER SOUNDING]
So who won?
Raise your hand if you
have more than 10 fish.
Sorry, go ahead and
count your fish first,
and then raise your hand
if you have more than 10.
Cool.
Yeah.
OK.
Only two people have more
than 10, three people, OK.
More than 11 fish?
OK.
So you guys each
have 12 or more.
Do you have 13 or more fish?
14 or more fish?
15 or more fish?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
How many do you have?
AUDIENCE: 15.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: 15.
[APPLAUSE]
Congratulations to the winner.
Great.
OK.
Awesome.
So talk to me.
Why was Commons hard?
What was hard about this game?
You guys can go ahead and yell
it out or raise your hands
as you wish.
AUDIENCE: You have
to have a strategy
that everyone agrees upon.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: You
have to have a strategy
that everyone agrees upon.
OK.
Anybody else?
What was hard about this game?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The thing that
was the best for the commons
was the most
damaging personally.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
The thing that
was best for the commons was
the most damaging personally.
Anybody else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it was unstable.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Cool.
So you weren't
quite sure how long
we were going to keep going.
Great.
These are all good answers.
And really the core of
this is if everyone acts
in their own interest, the
pond, the commons, dies.
This is called the
tragedy of the commons.
When anyone can access a
limited resource, it runs out.
Roads are another
really good example.
Anybody with a car
can access a road.
And soon enough
everybody is thinking,
if these idiots would
just take the bus,
I could be home by now.
Can somebody or can anybody
else name some other real life
examples of commons?
Think about limited resources
that anyone can access.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Air.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Air.
Say more.
Can you say more about--
AUDIENCE: Air pollution, how
we're-- just like you were
talking about earlier, how we're
abusing it and overusing it
with all these resources that
we think we need or want.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Yes.
So anybody can access the
air, and therefore, anybody
can pollute it.
Great.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Wireless internet.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
OK, wireless internet.
Say more.
AUDIENCE: So if everybody
watches Netflix in high HD
at the same time, nobody
can watch Netflix in HD.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
So if everybody
watches Netflix
in HD, then nobody
gets to watch Netflix in HD.
Because you don't
have enough bandwidth.
Great.
Any others?
Let's do one last one.
Any takers?
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Office mugs.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
Office mugs.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Tell
me more about office mugs.
AUDIENCE: If you have
reusable mugs in your office,
you have to rely on people
cleaning them and putting them
back for everyone else
to be able to use them.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Great.
So office mugs are something
that anybody in the office
can access, but
nobody's incentivized
to actually take care of them.
Great.
What about this one?
Earth is a commons.
We can all access earth.
We're all on it.
And certainly, it's limited.
So how do we solve commons
problems, either in the game
or in real life?
Does anybody have any ideas?
How did you guys
solve it in the game?
Let's start there.
AUDIENCE: Strategize together.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
Strategize together.
Cool.
Can you be more specific?
AUDIENCE: We talked
about how we would
be able to keep the most fish
on our plate or in our pond
by each just taking two.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
So you guys you guys
all ended up each taking two.
AUDIENCE: Not the entire time.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
Not the entire time.
OK.
Anybody else?
Why-- how do we solve common
problems, either in the game
or in real life?
What do you guys think?
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: If some people took
more, others would take less.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
So if some people--
if some people took more,
others would take less.
Great.
How did that work?
AUDIENCE: Not well.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Not well.
OK.
So it didn't work very well.
Well, the answer is, and when
we kind of came upon it already,
collective action.
We have to set rules in order
to solve common problems.
One example was,
let's all take two.
But we saw in your case
that sometimes those rules
get broken.
That's why climate
change is really hard.
But at any rate, setting
rules for everyone
is called politics.
Setting rules for everyone
is called politics,
and, therefore, protecting
the most important commons,
an inhabitable
earth, is political.
We need rules.
There is an issue.
Rules cost money.
For example, if I
can't sell my products,
because I emit carbon to
make them, I lose money,
and that's not acceptable to me.
So now we can
answer the question,
why haven't we done anything?
And the answer is, no one
wants rules limiting carbon.
But especially not
fossil fuel groups
who emit more than anyone.
You can see here, carbon
dioxide emissions by sector.
Residential and commercial
industry, transportation,
agriculture and land use.
Anybody want to guess
what that big blue one is?
AUDIENCE: Fossil fuels.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
Fossil fuels.
Energy, oil, gas, and coal.
Yeah.
The fossil fuel
industry has actually
known about climate
change for decades.
In 1978, more than 40 years
ago, Exxon's senior scientists
had this to say:
"Present thinking
holds that man has
a time window of 5 to
10 years before the need
for hard decisions regarding
changes in energy strategies
might become critical."
In other words, we
have five or 10 years
to figure out how to get
energy a different way.
He said that 40 years ago.
But fossil fuel companies spread
climate myths to the public,
including schools.
From 2003 to 2010,
Koch Family Foundations
and other fossil fuel groups
gave 558 million climate denial
organizations.
And I wish that I could share
more financial data with you,
but these groups are
secretive and hard to study.
In any case, the point is this.
Fossil fuel companies know that
rules will hurt their profits,
so they spread myths to the
public about climate change.
But now you know the truth.
You know that climate
change is real.
It's happening because of us.
It already affects you.
It will only get worse.
And we haven't done anything,
because fossil fuel companies
have lied to us for decades.
That leaves us with
one final question.
How do we shape our future?
We need to talk.
And I know that words
may seem inconsequential,
given some of the other
information I've shared.
But words give life to ideas
and ideas lead to change.
In other words,
your words matter.
I know it may feel
awkward, but studies
show that teens are actually
great at making parents
care about climate change.
Be open.
Be gentle.
Be honest.
You can try starting
with, "How do you
feel about climate change?"
In fact, on the count of three,
I want everybody to practice.
So on the count of
three, let's all
say, "How do you feel
about climate change?"
Ready?
One, two, three,
AUDIENCE: How do you feel
about climate change?
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
It's easy and it works.
I want to share one
last perspective
on why we need to talk.
It's not too late to
keep our paradise,
but we can't do it without you.
I'm going to leave you guys
with a five day challenge.
So go ahead and
write down the names
of five people you can talk
to about climate change.
You can do it on your phones.
You can do it on
a piece of paper.
But go ahead and
write down five names
of people you can talk
to about climate change.
Each day, each day for
the next five days,
talk about climate change
with someone on your list.
And remember, time
is of the essence.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
AUDIENCE: I noticed the
video presentation included
afforestation and reforestation
for the large solutions
to this problem.
Are there others
that we can consider?
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
A lot of the solutions
are collective based.
And by the way, I'll be
sending out a handout
to all of you guys
for things you can do
and informational
resources that you
can use for after this talk.
But to answer your
question, the main thing
that you can do in your life
is actually stop eating beef.
Cattle have a huge impact
on greenhouse gases because
of the methane they produce.
And so if you stop eating
beef, that's actually
the single biggest
contribution you
can make within
your personal life.
Obviously, if you are able
to drive less, fly less,
that's another huge one.
These are all ways that
you can contribute.
But as we saw, part of the
reason that climate change
is such a tricky problem
because we need everybody
to come together.
We need wind farms.
We need afforestation,
as you mentioned.
We need other kinds of
renewable energy resources.
But in your personal
life, don't eat beef,
talk about climate change, and
fly less are the top three.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: We talk a lot about
fossil fuels and transportation
and flying and things like
that, and same with beef.
We hear a lot about that.
And now people are starting
to hear more about plastics,
which is a use of fossil fuels.
But there's a lot
of fossil fuel uses
that are huge, like in
manufacturing processes
and things where we
could buy from companies
who use less fossil fuels.
But it's really hard for us to
find information about that.
Is there some sort
of resource for that?
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
I haven't seen any,
but I can follow up with you.
So I can send you
something after--
along with the handouts,
I'll have a answer for that.
I'll do the best that I can.
Thanks.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
parents would
you recommend a strategy
where you use the spiritual
[INAUDIBLE] argument that God's
given us this world to protect,
and it's a paradise and
we must protect nature.
Or the self-interest argument.
How do you think we should
lead that conversation?
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY:
That's a great question.
So the question is, how
should we talk to our parents
about climate change.
You know your parents
better than I do,
and that's part of why it turns
out that teenagers and kids are
actually so good at this.
Messenger matters
much more than message
when it comes to climate change.
And so if you come
to your parent
and say this is
important to you,
I think that's enough
to start a conversation.
Don't attack people,
including your parents.
That tends not to
be super helpful.
To quote one of the
professors here at MIT,
research shows that
showing research to people
doesn't work.
And so if you can
talk to your parents
from a personal
perspective and what
it means to you, that,
I think, is the best way
to start these conversations.
Stories and personal
impacts work a lot better
than graphs and data.
Yeah.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Cool.
Thanks.
Anybody else?
Awesome.
Oh, yes.
One more.
AUDIENCE: So what if you
come up against someone
who insists that it's not real?
How should I talk to
somebody who says,
well, I've been brainwashed.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: That's
a really hard question.
The question is how
do we talk to people
who are truly convinced that
climate change is not real.
If it's a stranger,
honestly, you're
probably not going to have much
of a shot at convincing them.
As I said, messenger
matters more than message,
and there's not--
you don't really
have the credibility
with that person
to sway their opinion
on something that they
hold so dearly.
But, again, if it's a relative,
start the conversation
with what climate
change means for you.
And as I said, I'll
send out resources
from NASA and from NOA and from
a bunch of other very credible
institutions that you can look
at to see more information
and why our models work.
And how we know
all of the things
that we know about
climate change.
And, of course, you're
more than welcome,
in fact, encouraged to share
that with your relatives
and friends and so on.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Thank you.
Do we have-- no.
Yes, in the back.
AUDIENCE: So it was a really
well done presentation
and I appreciated it.
My question is really
more form than anything.
Whenever you ask the question
about greenhouse gas effect,
is there like a number in your
head that you have before--
you'll ask a certain
number of people
before you just move on
for the sake of time?
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Cool.
I want to hold logistical
questions for afterwards,
but does anybody
have any questions
within the scope of
the presentation?
Anybody else?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Honestly
my, like, two cents
on Frank's question,
which is coming
from a very conservative
area of the country.
And a very conservative family
that not being confrontational
and just saying, this is how
I feel about climate change
and what's going on has actually
proven to have an effect.
Over years, yes.
It's been a slow process.
But saying the data
you're getting--
where you're getting this
information from is biased.
If you look elsewhere,
you'll see different data.
And then I just leave it.
And over time, they started
to see that and have started
to change their minds about it.
So that would be my two cents
from personal experience.
BRANDON LESCHINSKIY: Yeah.
That's a really good point.
So don't expect for
a single conversation
to completely change
somebody's mind.
That's really hard and unlikely.
But over the course of
these conversations,
I think you'll be surprised
and pleased at how successful
you'll be at changing
the minds of people
that are close to you.
Cool.
Thank you guys so
much for coming.
I really appreciate it.
And we can answer some
logistical questions,
but we don't need
to record that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]